[Music]
in fortune without Fame news oh I like
that
oh please submitted by love from the
pals named place on earth mr. Bella yeah
sounds like nipple I love it
Oh thinking like your pal but you in a
different direction
oh my bad a lottery winner is suing the
state for a non amenity to protect
herself from being a target Oh cuz they
announce all winners I thought you could
choose to be anonymous I would want to
be thank you can and that's why she's
suing because they broke the rule damn
she's gonna win the lottery and a core
and a suturing job but she lost her
anima Nana be so her life is never the
same again dude
and what if you spend all your lottery
winnings on the lawsuit no I don't think
she could spend 560 million five six
five hundred sixteen there was that her
a lottery winner a billion after taxes
two questions how old is she
and is she single she's an anonymous
right now so I don't know wow she wasn't
before me she wasn't but now she got it
no I thought that she wasn't beat was
all I explained so she won the Powerball
jackpot this takes place in New
Hampshire just so you guys know so in
New Hampshire as soon as the winning
ticket gets signed whoever signs that
ticket has to claim it publicly so she
did she signed the ticket and it cannot
be altered but they were saying that if
she did want to keep her anonymity she
would have had to create a she would
have had to create a trust fund oh and
then the trust fund could claim that
ticket and that's how she could stay
remain anonymous how do you notice that
that up but she can't do that anymore
because she signed the ticket she [ __ ]
up and now she's suing to try to still
keep her well she got enough money to
sue and is that common knowledge like
it's like everyone knows now if I win
this lottery ticket the only way to stay
anonymous is by also - and it depends on
what state you're in so for a New
Hampshire that would work if you're
worried about being targeted with
type of money you do realize you just
kind of move in there with the other
risk people where you're 560 million
means nothing family and friends like
she still wants to keep her life don't
you things that she wants to go to the
grocery store without having like a car
do you think you're drawing more
attention to yourself by making a court
case cuz now it's like she's under Jane
Jane Doe and also to when you have five
hundred sixty million dollars you don't
go to the grocery store [ __ ] you she
wants to do that yeah you're so [ __ ]
dumb do I win that yeah we exactly why
win the lottery what a waste yeah you
were you know I can't call you business
anyway
you [ __ ] easy and I'm sure he lives in
a place where no on this New Hampshire I
feel it what is she gonna do with that
money give it to me give it to me
publicly I don't care
ya have to come after me I don't give a
[ __ ] do what would you do if you know
there's only six states that that will
allow lottery winners to maintain their
an annuity its Delaware Kansas Maryland
North North Dakota Ohio South South
Carolina but New Hampshire is among the
few states that allow people to form a
trust to claim the prize money
anonymously so you're telling me if I
win all of this money in California
people have to know yeah and what
happens when people find out like what
are the things because we're already
kind of famous and it's like does it get
crazier there's there's been stories of
past lotto winners that they've been
targeted and like with this one man he
won and there's people that just stormed
into his home and killed him from in
front of his family
oh why just go back to your old home I
would have stayed out of there I would
have burned that place down and I want
to got myself a new home so right when I
win 560 million gasolina
so criminals are just looking at the
lottery list and yeah I'm gonna go there
and take their money why are we giving
criminals Homer there was this other she
worried too
no assignments every [ __ ] month damn
it there was this other story of this
man that won the lotto and this woman
approached him claiming to be writing a
book on how lottery winners winners are
like how they get scammed and after
years it turned out that she was
siphoning away his money and then when
he found out he was apparently he was
like oh I'm gonna kill you but then she
ended up killing him first
Wow so it attracts a lot of weirdos Hey
that money disappeared dude you could go
away for a year buy an island like a
dope one you know what if people follow
you no matter so if you go if you legit
have that money right hmm I would move
somewhere else
yeah you just leave your [ __ ] you mean
you could come back three four years
later people don't got a [ __ ] no
you're good I packed everybody up we all
go in somewhere how long do you have
people stalk you for do you think it's
like immediately and then it dies down
or like ten years later they go AHA no
it can't be ten years later because most
people I think would spend money spent
on the lottery perfect really smart was
it like this one person who won the
lotto twice and ended up bankrupt I
don't want to win a bit low end it you
don't know they don't you know like if
you're already in debt what makes you
think more money is gonna solve your
problem right that's a habit that
[ __ ] sucks in your life yeah I just
want to win a little lot of it I want
billions I want to be like yo yo yo
Zuckerberg yo let's go grab some
Starbucks coffee at the corporate
location I want to be with the CEOs I
just want to walk up to somebody slap
them in the [ __ ] face and they look
at me and I throw a [ __ ] $1000 in the
face I do something yeah take it so
confusing huh maybe forget the money on
the floor so what you gonna do or just
use a thousand to [ __ ] smack him in
the face cuz what if somebody came up to
you right now right yeah this is the
stack of money that they have let's say
this is like 10 G's they came up he was
slapped here they went here take this I
would take it right away
and Jesus said turn the other cheek give
me another thought
give me some already so that would
happen if I listen I won't even tell
them as I'm just gonna come up just oh
why just what you hit me cuz I [ __ ]
hate your face take this and then you
walk away it would be one of the ones
that lives in a trailer after just
wanted to beat so many people of this is
very true goodness
the dreams that are higher it's what
come up with somebody just go minor face
a bit right the forehead I'll probably
do that to the teachers that never
thought I was gonna amount to anything
like in yo face I want to be able to
spank my kids with one of these I would
probably just keep it your homework I'll
probably put it into an investment yeah
you don't need the investment when you
have that much money
yeah but then my legacy continues and
they don't have to suffer my legacy dude
I am NOT gonna create more spoiled
children
you know lock it only after they achieve
something yeah like it'll be like coded
like that I can give them a brand new 97
Honda Civic a brand new one that's a
nice car I'm trying to find that [ __ ]
right now it's impossible why do you
collect cars boxy cars no people are you
you'll never understand what goes on in
here well he's gonna win the lotto and
buy a bunch of [ __ ] cars run or anything
I live in a trailer
yeah okay I'm gonna get a 240sx
I'm gonna get that for sure I'm gonna
get a brand-new Honda Element 9 get rid
of my old ass one dancer I like that you
dream big David thank you that's why I
said I don't know what I would spend my
money on a pretty sure I would still
have like half a billion dollars just
because the things that I want nobody
really wants and it's not expensive at
all they're like okay you two take that
the beach and take a helicopter to work
Oh dudes like this is a junkyard sir why
are you here
I'm gonna buy my dream car did you win
the lotto like exactly
give me that Pinto this is a landfill
that's the exact car that I want I'll
build a castle in the middle of LA and
then no but it's [ __ ] up for every for
all of LA
let's pleasant to look at it's a castle
well after I build the castle
I will arm it with guards that have
super soakers and every time people walk
by don't be like the King's Guard oh
shoot at people and they're not a lot of
smile they have to like miserably
shooting so it's it's a non-stop water
fight
they'll be so funny what's the point of
doing it in LA because it's hot is it
just you that lives there or do you have
like parties or well you guys could come
if you want but not like open to the
public
nah but I would give homeless people
jobs and then they will all have super
soakers and then everyday like we'll
have a d-day kind of thing we're like
we'll have a water fight so then they'll
try to invade and then yeah see Jose the
guy that's gonna get killed it's gonna
live in the trailer yeah but see
originally before the Honda Element what
I wanted to do was take a Nissan transit
which is one of those like [ __ ] grip
transit yeah it's like these grip truck
it's it's not a really nice cars
basically a ban but the whole end but
the back is empty so you can go for a
catalog at home that only presents your
shitty car I'm looking for cards that I
could do whatever the [ __ ] I want with
this so in the very car though no not
any car you don't have the space or the
real estate for it so the Nissan Transit
how do you have the real estate in a
[ __ ] what did he want that is my
[ __ ] what was the other small a Mini
Cooper I don't want a Mini Cooper Steve
drives a mini-cooper I know it's like a
two-seater so he like goes all the way
back it's like he likes it but also
controls himself that's true like you
would not think that that's the car that
he drives but now he wants a truck I'm
like now you're just feeling you just
feel it like knows what the other
he was telling us about a story where he
has a brand deal email but to troll
himself because he doesn't want to have
to say yes to Brandon he only checks it
once a year and then there's a brand new
he really wanted but then he finally
checked it he was like what the [ __ ] I
could have got this like oh yeah i
trolled myself
yeah easy meals like big money dolla
dolla bills yeah and it's like dolla
with DOL la just gonna get so many
emails now your husband is by far one of
the most amazing men ever minimum that's
cuz he's got me behind him David yes I
just like the fact that he convinced you
that he was colorblind and then you're
like well what color to these in like I
don't know green and green and then for
a year I say that why wouldn't you
believe me it's so funny I lied to you
for a year okay I wouldn't even be able
to hold it in the bloodiest thing is the
reason why he told you is because he got
annoyed at the fact that you were
talking to like he's [ __ ] so funny
this guy scratches all of my non-stick
pans he cuts chicken in the pan with a
knife you tell me that you wouldn't get
sick of it I'll tell you this though I
hate that [ __ ] when I get nonstick and
then I see the roommates and they're
about to put a [ __ ] medal listen to
me you [ __ ] [ __ ] you see that
[ __ ] silicone spatula use that
[ __ ] [ __ ] see that's why I sound to
him and he calls it condescending well
how did you say to him hey you [ __ ]
[ __ ] how I say this on the body
[ __ ] yeah what I say is this hey
are you [ __ ] dumb it's not it's just
factual are you [ __ ] stupid what are
you doing
[Music]